hallo ihr lieben heute gibt es mal einen
ganz klassischen eintopf bewegen und so
richtung herbst und habe ich gedacht
irgendetwas das richtig schön schnell
geht oder so von innen wärmt ich mache
jetzt einfach direkt ich starte jetzt
direkt weil das video wird es auch nicht
so lang weil das halt wirklich ein sehr
schnelles rezept ist aber ich schreibe
euch alle ganzen mengenangaben hier
unten in die infobox und abonniert main
kanal falls ihr das noch nicht gemacht
habe denn dann verpasst ja auch keine
videos mehr und vor allem war das ein
vorschlag von euch über instagram als
auch gerne auf install um zeugen und
immer mal wieder vorschläge abgeben ich
werde jetzt zuallererst meine zwiebel
fein würfeln und dann zusammen mit
meinem fein geschnittenen lauch in einem
topf erwärmen dafür nehme ich heute ein
bisschen olivenöl zum anbinden
[Musik]
nachdem wir dann zwiebeln und lauch zwei
minuten angedünstet haben geben wir
möhren und kartoffeln dazu ich habs
jetzt meinem wellen schneider in schöne
kleine würfel geschnitten bei kartoffeln
nämlich am liebsten festkochende oder
vorwiegend festkochende aber wenig
kochen da würde ich jetzt nicht
empfehlen weil sonst gehen diese
auseinander wenn ihr das essen möchte
und das mag ich persönlich mich so so
das ganze kann jetzt schon gewürzt
werden
hauptbestandteil ist hier rinderbrühe
dann nehme ich gern meine die verlinkte
ich euch auch um die info-box und in
zukunft noch ein bisschen salz pfeffer
außerdem majoran und lorbeerblätter und
dann können wir alle schon mit kochendem
wasser auffüllen
[Musik]
bei mir kocht jetzt der einen topf ich
gebe jetzt den deckel drauf und dann
braucht das ganze so erst mal 20 minuten
danach gebe ich wüsst hiermit dazu wie
geflügel würstchen ihr könnt auch
rindswurst hinnehmen als was ihr möchtet
und die müssen dann wirklich nur noch 5
minuten ziehen also insgesamt braucht es
jetzt noch so 25 minuten und wenn es ein
bisschen weniger möchte dann gibt auch
gerne etwas speisestärke zusammen mit
wasser vermischt mit dazu und lass das
noch mal ganz kurz eindecken und somit
ist auch das ganze gericht lud ihn frei
wenn ihr könntet auch zum beispiel eine
mehlschwitze am anfang machen aber
darauf verzichte ich heute denn dann
kann auch alle davon essen die noten
frei ernähren
[Musik]
ich habe mir jetzt den haben sie dazu
gezogen für den test es den feiert er
immer so und warum das 2 ja ich
wusste ja ach so abonniert doch mal
unsere zeit kanal
ich wollte euch bescheid sagen dass ich
in den letzten 15 uhr den deckel
weggelassen habe denn so bekommt deshalb
wirklich noch seminar und dann ist es
wirklich in einen topf und keine suppe
aus wegen dem troicki decke glaubte ja
auf jeden fall probieren mal dass ein
typisch deutscher eintauchen der ist
echt typisch orientalische abwandlungen
sehen möchtet dann kommst du mal die
kommentare aber der super gesetzt ja ich
will dich das typisch durchgesetzt
deutsch wer da so ein bisschen moderat
gekürzt über geschmack lässt sich
streiten also beim bei den deutschen ein
stückchen salz pfeffer und muskatnuss
müsste ich hab das baureferat deutsche
küche möglich gewisse also das soll kein
bisschen an die deutsche küche aber dass
die wahrheit aber ich hab' ich glaube
das ist auch so bekannt unsere
kamerafrau die sag ich ja auch deutsche
was sagst du sitzen sie muss reden habe
ich eingebracht so würde sagen ja
typisch das nicht willst du ich hab noch
majoran und natürlich rinderbrühe
reingemacht ich habe ja auch meine
eigene rinderbrühe und ich finde die
wirklich sehr sehr lecker und die man
hat schon wirklich sehr viel geschmack
aus also ich würde sagen wir können und
so sitzt noch und falls ihr weitere
vorschläge habt rezeptvorschläge immer
unten in den kommentaren bruder peter
wilmanns und damit sehen wir uns
gar nicht auf einer wellenlänge
und du hast mich jetzt vor unterbrochen
also nur kurz lage weil es mir schon der
wochen hat wir sehen uns beim nächsten
mal wir halten macht machen abonnieren
ja auf jeden fall und jetzt mal südkorea
schaffen wir bei 123 hast du angst haben
keins ist ein großes ich will das ok 11
[Musik]